STARTED.
IT'S A GREAT GAME.
THERE ARE GREAT PEOPLE
MANITOBA.
AS WE ENTER THIS GAME, SELLEBUYF
LATE AND TERRIFIC MONTH OF
NOVEMBER AFTER A BIT OF A SLOWLE
LONG PASS AROUND THE BOARDS.
METS
ZONE AND WINNIPEG WILL GET THE
CHANGE.S THE FOURTH GAME SINCE
THE RETURN OF THE ROSTER
INJURIES.
BANGED UP A LITTLE BIT.
HERE IS THE FIRST CHANCE THAT
SIDNEY CROSBY GOES ACROSS.
STANLEY LETT BAT.
YOU CAN'T GIVE THESE TWO GUYS A
ONE
ANDREW COPP NOT THE ONLY ONE AND
CONNORH
THE SPEED.
WATCH FOR THAT.
>> CONNOR ON THE WING AND DROPSN
LONG PASS FROM THE JETS END.
WE WILL HAVE A W OWN
END.
AND QUICKLY TURNED AROUND BY OFN
OFF TO THE RICES OFF THE DRAW
IN THE --
DEFENCE IN THE OFFENSIVE Z TO P.
WIRES IT.
DOESN'T GET THROUGH.
THERE'S ANOTHER SHOT AND HE PUCK
HAND PASS CITING IT IN EARLY.
ANOTHER ONE HIGH SLOT OFF SIMONS
WOW, WHAT A CHANCE AND
NICE SEND BY BROCK MCGINN.
AND RIGHT AT THE VERY END
LITTLE DEFLECTION.
RIGHT THERE BY CARTER.
WHAT A SAVAVECOND EFFORT
AND THROWS IT TOWARDS THE NET AN
THE FRONT AND NO ONE CAN NUDGEDD
GREAT SAVE AND OTHER END ANDS
TIED THIS GAME BEATS
MORRISSEY TO THE PUCK AND JASON
ZUCKER W FRONT.
HELLEBUYCK WITH
AGAIN, HELLEBUYCK VERY SHARP AS
THE PUCK GETS INTERVIEWED GOING
THROUGH TORONTO OF COURSE THAT
THIS IS
DANTON HEINEN WITH THE GOAL.
THE PITTSBURGH PENGUINS ARE UP G
IN ON JARRY.
SETTLE IT DOWN.ENIED.
AND DOES.
JUST FANNED A LITTLE OF BROCK M.
THAT WAS A SHOT FROM HEINEN.
SAVE BY HELLEBUYCK. AND THROWS
IT TOWARDS THEBURGH PENGUINS ON
THE ROAD.